Jim Jefferies is early so it's good to
see you man all right thanks for having
me it's been a while me I haven't been
this room for a long time yeah
Allen used to be a completely different
stuff I was probably sitting next to you
yeah I was I think you were sitting in
this chair last time I was yeah yeah
that's the old Jim chair it is yeah yeah
now right now I know how many years it
takes to go around to that chair so
failing in a hamster that's what's gonna
happen
yep it's good to see how long you in
town for I'm doing I'm doing Fallon
tonight then I'm driving away but I I
think my family is on Friday but I'm
recording it tonight yeah they do
Thursday's for uh for Friday a new show
season two is the Jim Jefferies show
season two premieres next Tuesday March
27th at 10:30 they seem to kind of let
you do what you want to do on that show
they do they do they let me do it they
want to do what I want to do but they
also Comedy Central make me do
everything it's like it's like all those
other shows like Oliver or Samantha Vila
Daily Show or whatever they have people
doing field pieces and I did my field
piece for for the pilot which we it was
really fun Phil piece we went out to
Holland I don't know if you know this
they have a character called Black Pete
yeah oh yes at Christmas they do
blackface as a bit of fun right and not
just one or two people like everyone
does blackface celebration yeah and then
paints their lips red and stuff like
that it's meant to be like Santa's
helper and he's just like a guy who
hangs down so he did that feel peace and
they really liked it and then Comedy
Central like great you'll do all your
own field pieces again the other one but
I've just gotten back from Europe and we
did like I don't know maybe 10 or 12
different film comedies give to do one
for every episode yeah well almost every
episode we interview on the ones that we
you know we didn't have fill pieces but
we did like we went to Israel and did
the thing on circumcision just met like
the one guy who's really anti cutting
off the end of your [ __ ] in Israel
because you went all the way to Israel
for that I was digging there anyway oh I
was doing it [ __ ] let's play cuz she's
coming special pays for your flight yeah
tell a comedian would do it if I can
book your gigs around where they want to
shoot feel peace
I usually the feel [ __ ] come after my
gigs like you just go right we're in
Stockholm what's there's nothing with
Phil pacing in Stockholm uh-huh oh the
healthcare is really good in the women
are beautiful see if we can [ __ ] rock
some story out of this so you stay for
an extra day or two you do that and you
move on no we just do it we do it the
morning before the shows we go right we
bash him out man
have you seen the circumcision
protestors here in the states have their
bane oh my god I had him on when I was
doing the night show I had them up there
like there they wear all white yeah
except they have a big blood stain on
their white pants where they're this is
what we do yeah the white pants with the
blood stain and then he just stands
around
yeah just yells at people about having
they're angry with me I'm circumcised I
bet I got my son circumcised and he got
really angry at me for doing that like
basically called me a child mutilator
and I am but I don't agree with with the
terminology you know like that
terminology I've mutilated him in other
ways I've cut his face up he's misspoke
what I did to his dick was wrong no
absolutely not
I wish I was uncircumcised though I've
talked about this I wish I was on yeah
yeah I we've had this discussion you
reckon it would feel better oh yeah the
sex would feel better but how how do you
how do you first of all guys say you
know because people have said it or
whatever yeah everyone's already got the
one dick you really have to make like
one person
he's got the whose ID that dick right
had a bit of sex then had the dick cut
off and then had a bit more sex which is
plenty of people have had circumcisions
in their knees
and then just ask how they went but do
you really like how much you
masturbating awake usually once a day
but I made myself start using Lube now
just just like because my dick was like
it's just a twisted root I couldn't feel
anything was just numb
okay but you're still doing it once a
day why do you need to step then
sensation up play why do you have to
start going oh I need this to be better
sometimes I don't even want to do it
what do you do that's a great question
you asked myself that a lot Varma once a
Dyer
I'm at least there one day today if you
were if you were uncircumcised and you
were doing it once a day you still
wouldn't be where would you be saving
your sensitivity my sex would be I just
think he'd be some more sensitive you've
had it he had it done as an as a young
adult he ain't
team you and nineteen why did you got
done well I had it Matt my my foreskin
didn't roll back yeah that's nothing yet
my uncle had the same thing it's like
it's just why would you want to take the
risk I just get it done when you're a
baby
exactly and how do you feel now that
you've had the amazing yeah it's great
different suppose enjoy looking at it
now I that's the thing there's an
aesthetic thing about it the girls like
a lot of girls think it's losing there's
never been a sex toy with a foreskin
that's all you enjoy the foreskin that's
a good point there's a lotta Caroline it
gets gross they do but you had a medical
condition where his dumb dick skin
wouldn't come all the way down so it
look like somebody putting on a shirt
that was too small exactly it couldn't
work like foreskin is supposed to so you
kind of have the hole in the neck that's
so small it's the rest of the body like
you're talking about a person with a
gigantic head yeah and they just [ __ ]
top of the head go through your shirt
not the rest yeah you can see my head
like you see my hair kind of almost but
no it's not happening yes you needed to
get it done medically some guys just do
it because they they get sick of the
foreskin rocco siffredi did it I heard
he regretted it oh the I you know the
porn star Rob you know he used to be my
favorite porn star yeah he was great
right him nacho it was really that was
an era in the 90s when I used to do
terrible Joker and this is you know I
don't know if I I could still do this
joke now but it used to be like raucous
if Eddie's my favorite porn star and
people used to go why do you like why is
your favorite porn star a male I go
because sometimes when you're watching
him have sex with a woman your brain
actually goes she might die now
obviously I don't do jokes like that
anymore but that that was a fun thing
back in the day way back then now have
you gotten to a different time how do
you actually worry uh
because you know as a comic you're
pretty you said whatever you wanted to
say do you do you start to worry like
all right [ __ ] I got to be a little well
no just well obviously
okay because before we'd stand up you
have plausible denial where you're going
well
see that's a joke and I don't mean that
I don't want anyone to get hurt or
anything like that you know I mean and
it's something outrages that you're
saying even when you're doing a comedy
show if it's news and fact base you
can't say anything to that level on the
account that because all of a sudden now
what I'm saying is fact factual or can
actually be quoted where before comic
comedy stand-up comedy can't really be
quoted because you're gonna go that was
obviously a joke and even though these
other things are jokes and even things
that you say in here like I've said a
lot of rubbish in here you go what's the
that's why I'm not a Trump fan but I
that they always pull up those clips of
him on stones saying something I'm like
no [ __ ] that man that's what people do
on that show yeah
you know I mean I'm not gonna I'm gonna
condemn the guy because he said
something about a beauty pageant saying
or even even say that that's a fact that
he did these things that he said on the
show trying to impress Howard he's
Howard you know he's just trying but
then like him on the bus with Billy Bush
it's like yeah you did that that's a
private I would be more confident that
he didn't do that if they if they like
there in front of the camp sure there in
front of the camera I got always just
being an [ __ ] but on the bus where
he's like where's my tic tacs
and it's an awful it does nothing for
your breasts make sure to [ __ ] it
just makes your mouth dry yeah terrible
take time and it's also and it's just it
makes a rattle like everyone knows
you're conscious every way I I was once
with a mate of mine when I was a when I
was about maybe I was 10 or something
you know you had that friend that just
shoplifted constantly sure this couldn't
help himself was always shoplifting at
least one mate
and he and we were in the store and he
was doing his shoplifting and I could
never do it because I just that my
parents would kill me and the guilty
conscience and I'll do that anyway he
stole a you know like a value pack of
Tic Tacs it's like 10 of them like
wrapped in cellophane just didn't like a
thing right and he shoved it he shoved
that Danny's pants leg and then as we're
leaving the security goes hey stop I
want to check your pockets and he goes I
don't I think my pockets and he takes a
step
he's like you kids come back now I
remember running away from the
supermarket just kids you gotta shop
with candy don't make it tic tacs yeah
it's still quiet [ __ ] you you got into
it with Piers Morgan to which which I
think that kind of went everywhere
people talked it yeah do you dislike him
or did you see in that mother tell you
what no I do dislike him but what was it
what was it about yeah it was about him
saying it wasn't a Muslim ban this was
like the week that that Trump had said
this band that ban this meant like these
countries these countries can't come in
and yes it wasn't a Muslim ban because
his argument was that there's other
countries that have Muslims and they're
not having problems travel bans because
it's not a Muslim ban and I'm like
saying well that's like saying if you
make a few because because the people
always use the argument that you're
trying to ban guns and it's like gun
controllers and gun bans so maybe I
should have been more eloquent and say
well it's Muslim control rather than a
Muslim ban because he is right it wasn't
a complete wuss event but I'll tell you
what really happened there over the
years at times I have stirred up Piers
Morgan on Twitter for no apparent reason
I haven't made I have like if he said
it's we'd have tried to upset him and
write some stupid little thing or
something like that anyway I had no idea
I was doing the Bill Maher show and so I
sent out a tweet that was like as banal
as hey everyone I'm on the Bill Maher
show at 10 o'clock or 11 o'clock or
whatever tune in tonight right
and he wrote underneath it and I didn't
know he was the other guest
I'll be sitting six feet away bring your
a-game and I thought if I get a chance
to take a potshot at this kind I'm gonna
take it I was already a little bit
rolled up before that all happened I
thought if I get an opportunity I'm
gonna time to [ __ ] off
yeah and he did he did one thing like I
was being a bit child is just sort of
just yelling over him and lots of stuff
but he did one thing that was stupid
with comics where he went oh come on now
Jim you're losing your crowd and I knew
the crowd were enjoying it so to speak
am I losing you and they went
and you know that and then it was like
oh these guy Marcus know whatever a walk
right I got it no yeah you never want to
say that if it's going well you're
losing your crowd especially if they're
laughing and having fun you like do you
guys talk after the show afterwards they
made us take photos and I just I just
put my arm around him for like the group
photo and I wish Ben he a bit of fun in
a piece yeah like that rights button
he's since commented on that saying and
all he was all hugs and smiles
afterwards but you know I look I what I
think he's a he's a contrarian I think
he just likes doing [ __ ] I think he
likes being that villain that people all
tell off or whatever so I try not to
give him too much power but I'm sure
he's happy we're talking about him right
I do and I enjoy I love having him on
the show because no matter what he's
talking about if I don't agree with it
or if I agree with it which is you know
4060 I don't disagree with him it mean
him on gun control we've got a very
similar thing yeah it's fun to watch him
riling people up though because yeah
yeah I love that he's the only guy
that's like he's riling everybody up by
talking about how much we need gun
control and then he's riling everybody
up again by supporting Trump on stuff
it's like he doesn't yes
that was my whole point you only like
Trump because you're on the Celebrity
Apprentice and you enjoy the fact that a
good friend of yours is the president
and that was that was my point
now I also think and I know this might
be silly of me because this is before
Trump and everything like that
I think he didn't like me because he
always considered him just be the
foreign guy who talked about gun control
and then when I had that peace go viral
he got a little jealous of others now
another foreign person talking about gun
control yeah I think that hurt him a
little do you get [ __ ] talking about
American I know they give pierce show
you don't even live you don't you from
America that I do enjoy that yeah you're
not from here go home and look I have in
my mind the moral high ground that I I
make a good living up a shitload of
[ __ ] taxes like [ __ ] you then I take
my tax money if you don't want it you
know I mean and and also you know
between me and you and everyone
listening I should be an American
citizen before the end of the year
oh wow that's great sorry sorry I I
don't know what their response is going
to be after that
with ready was there any part of you
that was like I don't know if I really
want to go this deep into politics cuz
once you know you start the show on
Comedy Central yeah like now this
becomes your thing yeah and whereas
before for the most part the word on Jim
Jefferies was if you know him it's like
oh yeah largerr he's the man now there's
half the audience going like [ __ ] that
guy yeah it used to be on my forums like
oh this guy's great he's fine he did
this stupid thing with a porn star on
the opening Anthony show like stupid
stupid [ __ ] we used to do here and now
it is a bit more split with [ __ ] that
guy literally Libertad [ __ ] which I was
but the funny not funny one of the more
odd things I've had to experience for
doing this show is is I don't have an
opinion on everything you know when a
news story happens I used to watch news
stories like this and be like hey all
right well I wonder how that will play
out now I have to be on TV and give an
opinion right and so that's a different
thing
so what you have to do kind of read into
it a little bit more or actually just
kind of think like how would I feel
about this if I gave it yeah exactly
exactly there's some things you gotta go
how would I feel about this like you
know and then you start giving a [ __ ]
because it used to be I watched maybe an
hour of news a day and now we just have
in the office we have news playing 24
hours a day and we have like multiple
TVs in each room playing all the
different channels so we're not just
being filtered why and to us constantly
so so we we are listening to both sides
other stuff but I try on the show to
like you know I'm fairly left-wing but I
found out that I'm nowhere near as
left-wing as many people are I'm not
even close how some people are cuz like
things like like like like we did a
piece on like kids wanting to dress up
as that Hawaiian Disney character and
people had a muara and and there's
cultural appropriation absolutely no I
don't agree with that [ __ ] off with the
kid dress like Milano that's how I feel
right now yeah yes there's there's
certain little things like that where
I'm like no and then I'm you know even
I'm like what we're trying to write a
piece at the moment about how what
sports transgender people should be
allowed to play like if you identify as
a woman and you've had the sex change
should you
be allowed to compete against women and
I'm like and some things I'm like sure
yes but then in boxing I'm like no but
then I get I got some riders on my staff
we were very left-wing who are like no
but once you take the hormone your bone
density changes and you this changes in
here that changes it does not change
that much and Rogin at a good point
about ligaments yeah
you're born male ligament it stop it
doesn't change that much it does not
change enough to compete physically
against other ones but that's also these
things in life that you have to go
alright I've done this in my life
therefore I can't do certain other
things right so me personally they're
saying they're taking the drugs they
have to complain I've taken a shitload
of cocaine therefore I'm not allowed to
compete in the Olympics either because
they wouldn't pass the test right so
there's choices you make but I don't for
a second believe that anyone is cutting
their dick off so they can win a gold
medal that's not like I'm a [ __ ]
metal guy who needs a dick when you have
a gold medal yeah but it's crazy I
people get so radical about that like if
you if you if you even have an opinion
like I'm not sure about that they
[ __ ] yeah I found out that my opinion
person is it's a case-by-case thing you
know there's certain sports and there's
certain things and it's like it and each
person has to be evaluated on on
themselves like I shouldn't be competing
in any boxing match either and I'm still
a man right like I'd probably die
there'd be something if they ran tests
on me they'd see that I'm not
appropriate for one reason or another
yeah you shouldn't be competing i watch
women fight they're 115 pounds stroyed
right and I'm like I know that that
woman could could could damage me and
kick the [ __ ] out of me I'm 145 pound
guy I would lose that fight because I
just know I would lose it so get any man
on that card like everybody on that card
could kick the [ __ ] out of any of us
fighters yeah yeah well I met many
packages once I think I was doing like
going
Adam Carolla or something and the other
the other guess was Manny Pacquiao
anything guys a [ __ ] right it's a
little fella it's a little Tony [ __ ]
like anyway your writers would not be
happy that you were using the word
[ __ ] that's true yeah your writers
would be upset with you look at him like
if he even just slightly sort of looked
me the wrong way I think I could take
this guy Yeah right
yes and you could hit him as hard as you
wanted and he wouldn't flinch
do you have Rob Anil on the show yeah
yeah yeah so so Rob come did my TV show
and I sort of party a little bit was
right every now and again he came out
and hung out with me in Vegas and stuff
there's something about us for the
people who are hearing this person Rob's
the guy who shot bin Laden and then he
was SEAL Team six whenever I'm in a bar
with Rob and Rob drinks he just got
kicked off a plane right yeah it's like
in the office he drinks Jim and I both
took the stance that he should be
allowed to drink as much as he wants to
on any plane that you can treat the
stewardesses however you want to treat
them and then remind everybody that you
shot bin Laden yes yeah you know what I
did for the airplane industry yeah
exactly
you're all comfortable again you're
welcome yeah so um in Vegas why are you
that may being on a plane did not jump
off a helicopter that crashed right into
bin Laden's compound yeah like don't
worry about me if there's an emergency
I'll get off the plane Jeff's voice I'm
gonna get all of us off the plane anyway
so so whenever I'm dreaming with him I
like if someone you know here like
someone bumps into you and spills your
drink you always like ah don't worry
about it and the person's like oh okay
if someone's even like slightly rude to
me and I'm staying with Rob and I'm
drunk I feel like I should start a fight
[Laughter]
like I haven't started an adult I
haven't been in a fight since high
school but I feel like if you're willing
to you're gonna win
now's the time you're gonna do this yeah
god I had some type of Vulcan grip rages
on kills a person yeah yeah I'm pretty
sure in SEAL team 6 they go over
hand-to-hand combat right and oh so that
we think is Rob's bodyguards other SEAL
Team six is
then when other guys who just retired
who's Garen to him of these talks and
because yeah Isis are looking for him or
something say he's yeah he's a teaser
legit target who's a guy they'd like to
get their hands on if they could yeah
yeah and sorry the guys I hate so it's
like whenever you're drinking with him
it's always like another two SEAL Team
six guys see you like alright but this
is what I don't get
you got SEAL Team six what are the other
five SEAL Teams doing what are we what
are we always rely on six yeah he's like
number five Catering some [ __ ] job we
have a big mission well it's not that
big of a mission SEAL team three is
going in its the transgender boxes
really suck it used to be if you said
you were a Navy SEAL guy it would be
like oh my god you must know everything
but now if you're like are you on SEAL
Team six and they like no it's like oh
so you're just just Navy season C hold
on yeah what are the guys in this still
team six that he always hangs out with
is obviously being shot in the [ __ ]
hip or something and he's all walks with
a cane and his days of being a thottie
hard
no he's just one of his mates that comes
and hangs out every night again
and he walks with like a cane and I
always think and like he's slow you know
it's like it's a proper limp it's not
just like I've hurt my ankle it's a real
straight good something's happened yeah
and I'm still think that guy could still
probably probably kick the [ __ ] out of
me
even with that that shitty leg for sure
even that shitty leg he balanced himself
he grabbed it with the other leg and
[ __ ] swing the [ __ ] leg into me
yeah just licensed to carry a firearm
and a Potter's gonna point get away from
me but yeah a SEAL Team six member that
needs a cane to walk it's not an injured
guy it's a guy with a weapon is it does
it stop at sixth we go to seven I don't
think if we've never heard it don't
forget we didn't know SEAL Team six for
a long time that's true now there might
be a seven I don't know what six means
or if there's four if there's just seals
and steals Ickx maybe there's not five
other ones like what an area of 50 to 51
that's we all know about it we all know
about it right
you got to [ __ ] move that yes the
least secretive place well right there
yeah it's area 51 is where they keep all
the islands and
now which makes me wonder is there
another 50 other areas they're the same
ones right and what are we stockpiling
in those runs is blankets 51 is the hack
area that's where everybody knows oh
that's what we think
[ __ ] is but it's not all the aliens are
an area 17 nobody ever talks about is
area 17 right it's not just in Burbank
it has to Universal Studios right it's
in the suburbs well there was a guy who
wrote a book about it and he said that
way after the Roswell crash no again
this is just this guy that they were
shipped off to a military base I've made
I'm McCarran every one of the an Air
Force Base or something and that all
this the UFO stuff is stored under
foreign technologies because this way
the press can't get in to him and look
at him and technically it is foreign
technology yeah yeah there's or a
foreign weaponry that it's it's stored
under something that the press knows
that they can't access because it's
classic we have to look I was always a
believer in what type of style I do
believe there's there's smart
intelligent life on it there's
definitely aliens there's definitely
dumb bugs on summer and some dust bug or
a [ __ ] maggot in some [ __ ] planet
sure of course there's things happening
in other planets where they have UFOs or
something I don't know but I've decided
to having visitors I decided there's no
Bigfoot
there's no [ __ ] like next monster
there's none of that [ __ ] you think the
Earth's flat no it's going against all
conspiracies I tell you why because I
used to sort of believe I wanted to
believe in all those things that there
was different thing but I can't [ __ ]
have a piece in an alleyway without
someone taking a video of me yeah you
know I mean you're putting on your Jim
Jefferies having a piece in an alley
what yeah you know a strip club and
people start taking photos let me having
lap dances and you don't even have a
camera and it's like where everyone's
carrying a camera all the [ __ ] times
right yeah we usually have to pass off
this grainy footage of a Bigfoot and go
or maybe that said what did I just say
and it's like not now you don't think
any aliens on earth there's no aliens
there's no definitely no Bigfoot's no
Bigfoot
well that guy's thing I think his name
was Robert Johnson the guy but the 1967
footage where he's kind of like running
and then the the surgeons photo of Loch
Ness monster he admitted was a fake on
his head no no ghosts no ghosts no
guards or when we die we just go in the
ground
yes yes yes really but if we are a ghost
if we if there are ghosts we're not
visible
no one's gonna you get on YouTube and go
footage of ghosts it's always like a
photo from the 1950 that's overexposed
where luckily you got like you know it's
the same as Jesus in a tortilla right
you can sometimes get a bit of luck with
the burn marks there's like [ __ ] is that
one where Jesus looks like the dogs
[ __ ] Jesus dog dog [ __ ] picture
and then you'll see like like Zog bomb
they call it respectful dog bomb yeah
Wow dogs are so looks like Jesus my god
maybe he's the second coming
it really does look like Jesus does I
see it maybe is now I have two reasons -
he's got he's got fee and he's got the
arms he's at the closing that that dogs
I saw does look like Jesus Wow it
certainly does yeah but so so I mean if
we see a moldy stain in a [ __ ] house
in Mexico and people start praying to it
it's just there are full seasons of
television devoted to being ghost
hunters and there is zero compelling
evidence on any of them it's like
Finding Bigfoot who is watching Finding
Bigfoot like today's the day they find
Bigfoot now release it they would have
leaked hey they're not gonna go we'll
hold on to this for season four I don't
know I've been watching a Tupac and
Biggie shmurda the series on USA and I'm
pretty sure by the end they'll figure
out who did it well it's okay take a
bite yeah there's no bit why would you
like a bite yeah it's only bagel you got
heart I was in Mexico recently I was in
like a [ __ ] village all right like
this is a real slummy Pais and someone's
like Jim Jefferies gun control right no
if all I can't do that I'm only mildly
famous [ __ ] two packs living in
somewhere right two packs don't leave it
anywhere Elvis what Elvis baby
how does he'd be [ __ ] ID I mean I
guess but placed in South America the
Nazis hit he could be down there Brazil
Argentina the Nazis hit Elvis no but I
mean there's places to hide but could
they just need to lose some weight and
he would have looked like different a
lot different shaved his hair so
obviously there's a guy go there's a guy
called Jesse Presley and there was
there's a girl he said that she was
related to him and there was DNA you
know what type of stuff and there was a
guy that I thought was Elvis I'd like of
us to be alive I would I write I write a
movie spec and I tried to sell years ago
called Gavin has left the building
and the idea behind Gavin left the
building it was like a new take on that
maybe Dave remembered for several days
it was basically like what happened to
the guy who is the the the body double
of Elvis the guy who wore the sunglasses
had the scarf and like when Elvis went
out that door he was the one who walked
through the limo at that door and then
after he does that there were most of
the shots when we used to see Michael
Jackson with the magical mask on was
because that was the body double and
there was a guy that just used to have
to keep on getting plastic surgery so
his eyes were Kate the keeper wow I
didn't realize that and that's where we
was at a surgical mask because all these
people always have someone leaving a
different building or something like
that so this there's the name speaking
of Elvis there's and impersonators and
stuff there's an incredible documentary
on Netflix called Orion and it's about
this guy who I guess was like they tried
to make him into a pop star who's just
this guy who sounded like Elvis oh yeah
he does yeah and he wanted to be a pop
star so bad and all he wanted to do was
sing professionally and he just wasn't
getting any breaks and wasn't getting
any breaks until somebody said he didn't
really look like Elvis but somebody said
you can soar do you sing just like Elvis
and if we put like a Lone Ranger mask on
you we can kind of market you as my
second coming maybe he's bringing out
albums and I mean it was such a the way
like his life is like saying Unchained
Melody a great Elvis cover
[Music]
Wow granny yes Sam ago but he didn't
want to be this Elvis right he wanted to
be himself but this is all over the only
way he that's how he sings yeah I love
that vest one my favorite videos on
YouTube is fat Elvis singing this while
the guy holds the mic in his face he's
absolutely obese and he's sweating
yes it's an awesome video all right I
always think that about Elvis Elvis died
I'm one year older than when all this
died now when you're out with these
cutie SEAL Team six guys do they do you
just listen to stories that they tell
cause like there's not like oh how do
you tell a story with Tia seem like they
rescue the lone survivor and Captain
Phillips and yeah right they do the same
group same group yeah all the same group
who did all those things so so they
always have like an interesting sort of
they can drink like these guys you know
which movie do you think based on your
their stories is the most [ __ ] is it
the zero dark thirty seemed pretty our
pretty odd pretty answer doctor captain
Phillips
yeah zero dark thirty say mostly I have
a real thing but I look captain Phillips
and I only come in at the a yeah I am
the captain no we heard this story how
he just made that up and they kept it in
it was a fascinating interview really no
no he was a nice band but the guy who
played the Pirates Somalian wonder who
won the Oscar oh really
he did win the Oscar correct he did when
is he still gig where do you nominated
win the Oscar nominee just got nominated
cuz everybody realized how silly it
would be for him to win the I yeah he
played the first acting gig but is he is
he had a gig since night that he's
looking I don't know this had one he
might have played kind of a similar role
he's had he's had a couple but I do
think that he thought this was gonna be
no no more candy gotten cup three he
wasn't
I am in charge how do you go from being
nominated for an Oscar a lot of guys
that fought Timothy Hutton won the Oscar
in 1980 you and 80 ramen diets no one
from the Oscar for ordinary people Best
Supporting right and it just kind of but
you got it I mean that's kind of like a
crazy like that's a sad story but you
kind of got to know your spot when
you're the guy who plays the Somali
pirate in Captain Phillips I kind of got
a no the yes special him it's a special
case probably maybe doing some more
foreign films and stuff like that but
what happens to like case Marisa Tomei
we didn't hear about her forever right
and it's like she never lost her hotness
something like that and then when she
came back was like really like the
wrestler before we saw her that's right
I think they came back and we were all
like [ __ ] there's a few episodes of
Seinfeld in there they did the whole
thing but we were like [ __ ] she did
nothing forever all right she won the
Oscar yeah she really she still does
look relatively good she's amazing she
looks bangin me way more than relatively
you know really 50 yeah she's very cute
I had a thing for her she didn't movie
with Robert Downey jr. that I had a
thing for her back when I was a teenager
before we could have another one it was
like a romantic comedy called remember
being in love or some [ __ ]
today I remember wanking off to it
several times oh yeah I did too to the
other one now what was the one game I
got those zero with [ __ ] James Spader
James yes I know I'm butchering the name
he plays a drug addict Robert Downey jr.
that was that was when he actually was a
drug addict yeah like this young
generation see him is this suave he's
Iron Man Iron Man he's like this and and
it's like but we're like there was
movies where it was like all Robert
Downey jr. he was like charleshayne it
for a wallet yeah he was he was while he
was great in that movie - he played this
[ __ ] coke addict that he's being
pimped out by some guy really good
really late fell in less than zero
yeah it was like a 87 when James Spader
was this like hey he played every time
there's a rich douchebag it was James
Spader the wrestler was supposed to be
the return for Mickey Rourke and it
ended up being the return for Marisa
Tomei
yeah Mickey Rock had a he had a little
bit of a Ronnie to the iron man I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna name drop
really badly here but like Brad Pitt
plays my weatherman on my TV show he's
on like three episodes that's amazing
that's just a stupid weird thing but
he's very easy accurate yes comes on he
talks about I just he just watched my
comedy specials and then he asked he
asked Netflix asked me to interview him
for something and then he said as a
favor he'd come and do my show and then
but like the only reason I'm name of
that is he I said like who's your
favorite actor what actor do you and he
said Mickey Rourke Mickey Rourke really
I said young Mickey Rourke was the best
actor he ever saw so there you go it's
amazing